hey there townscapers and welcome back
to my channel if this is your first time
here welcome and thank you for coming
today
do me a favor and hit the like button
subscribe and share this video with
other people if you think they would
enjoy the content this would help me out
a whole lot and i would really really
appreciate it
i just wanted to show you a couple of
things i noticed while i was playing
around with lighthouses
there are a lot of combinations you can
use to achieve a certain look like flags
and lighthouses on staircases and
cranes and stuff like that so i'm just
going to play with it a little bit so
you can see what i'm talking about
so first off we want to acknowledge what
oscar said and that is that the last
three blocks have to be different colors
we can just call it the rule of three
for this video you need three blocks
from the cobblestone base to generate a
lighthouse
it doesn't have to just be cobblestone
on water because lighthouses can be
generated on cranes as well as
raised or floating platforms so the base
would pretty much be where the tower
starts so the rules and requirements
they can vary depending on what you're
doing or where you are on the grid
that's something that i noticed
and another townscaper even mentioned
that if you place an individual block of
cobblestone
that counts as one block and when you
add two more blocks the lighthouse
generates so it really just depends on
what you're doing so let's go through
the rest of these examples
if you want to place your lighthouse on
a crane it goes by the rule of three
where the crane is the first block not
the base of the crane
if you want flags on your lighthouses it
actually varies between three and four
and that means depending on where the
tower is based it has to be a minimum of
three blocks four blocks for the flags
to generate and they
will start on the second block so you
can notice it when you place it
depending on where you are once you make
the third block
appear the flags will appear on the
second block
the same applies if you're building on
an individual block so you have to place
the individual block then build three
blocks high to four blocks high
depending on where you are
on that grid
if you want to obstruct the flags or
block in between you it's still going by
the rule of three so
if you have to make sure that you don't
obstruct the last three blocks if you
want to keep the lighthouses
if you don't want to get rid of the
flags but you do want to close the
middle space off
what you can do is you can place a block
in front of it but it goes by rule of
four
so if the tower is only three blocks
tall it will keep the flags but it won't
be a lighthouse so the tower has to be a
minimum of four blocks tall to achieve
this look
also notice if you add more blocks in
that space that you would have to add
another level to the towers in order to
keep the lighthouses
you can also add staircases in between
those lighthouses
so onto staircases and this is the last
part of it but
when you end up in a situation where the
lighthouse is accent the stairs such as
building a larger staircase with the
lighthouses on the side
one important thing to remember is that
the towers cannot connect if they touch
each other then they won't turn into
light houses
they follow the rule of three but it's a
little tricky sometimes because if you
start at the bottom of the staircase the
tower has to be four blocks tall so you
place the base and then you add the four
blocks but if you are at the middle or
the top of the staircase and you place a
block on the wall it requires three
blocks from the wall
and an individual tower on the base is
only three blocks from that base
if you want to place them on the side of
your staircase it's still technically
going by the rule of three but the base
block is already placed
so there's a base block on the wall but
then you would place three more blocks
to go on ahead and make the lighthouse
um and that's it for this video i had a
lot of fun messing around with the
lighthouses i'm sorry for all the crazy
townscaper math that i just came up with
uh but i figured it would be
in my opinion that was the best way for
me to explain it i guess but anyways i
just want to thank you guys so much do
let me know in the comment section if
you tried this out or if you saw any
other combinations that i missed
again thank you thank you thank you
please make sure to like subscribe and
share as it will really really help me
out and i would really appreciate it
i'll see y'all next time
stay safe